[Music]
on this thursday night trying to blunt
the impact of omicron
the call for a circuit breaker in
ontario data is very clear that this is
incredibly transmissible are more
restrictions coming plus why frontline
healthcare workers hope the variant will
be easier to treat as frustration mounts
for pandemic fatigued travelers
some revealing moments in a year-end
interview with the prime minister one
moment that touched me perhaps more than
anything else what he had to say about
the two michaels and sexual misconduct
in the military
and lost hope in afghanistan there's a
ten-year-old girl who was shot in the
face
when she should have been on her way to
canada why are afghans approved to come
to canada not getting here
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are continuing to track the rapid
spread of omicron tonight and its impact
on all our lives in quebec case numbers
are surging to record levels and the
premier has just announced public health
restrictions are being reimposed
starting on monday all businesses will
be limited to fifty percent capacity
bars restaurants theaters and places of
worship will also go down to fifty
percent capacity with the holiday just
around the corner social gatherings will
be limited to a maximum of ten people
indoors
everyone has a great
responsibility
if everyone does their part we can get
through this together
i'm counting on you all
the montreal canadiens have announced no
fans will be allowed at tonight's game
in montreal at the request of provincial
health officials in ontario science
advisors say immediate intervention is
also necessary and are calling for
another so-called circuit breaker of
measures to reduce social contacts by 50
percent
this will likely be the hardest wave of
the pandemic
but if we can control it and drive
vaccination as hard as we can
we can make it to the exit it's not a
lockdown it's not a stay-at-home order
but it does require reduction in
contacts
ontario is accelerating booster doses
which offer greater protection against
serious illness and it is limiting
capacity at big venues like sports
arenas but without further measures the
science advisors say admissions of
coveted patients to critical care could
in a worst-case scenario reach 600 by
the new year that is assuming omicron is
as severe as delta early evidence shows
milder infections but there's not enough
data to say for certain and the variant
is moving faster than we can react no
new public health restrictions were
announced in ontario today as abigail
beeman reports canadians are left
bewildered frustrated and not sure how
worried they should be
it's been
so long more than two years and
well i think we decided to go to visit
our families
calgary's departure wings still busy
after a new advisory from ottawa warning
against non-essential travel there is
some concern
you know what's going to happen coming
home we're gone for six days so the
border is going to be closed do we have
to quarantine for two weeks we are
anticipating a very busy christmas
season westjet is slamming the blanket
advisory calling for more data and while
they expect some cancellations and say
canadians have that option they also
point out we've seen this advisory
before the level three travel advisory
was actually in place all summer long
and into the fall and we carried the
most guests that we've ever carried
throughout throughout the summer since
the onset of the pandemic the difference
now omicron already dominant in ontario
and new modeling from the province's
science table warns it could have
greater impact than any variant yet that
modeling predicts if nothing is done
cases could rise to six to ten thousand
a day in two weeks ontario topped 2400
today it transmits incredibly fast with
evidence two doses of pfizer are less
effective against omicron than delta and
three are better the science table is
calling for a boost to the booster
campaign and a circuit breaker i believe
we can do this without closing schools
or shutting down businesses that have
suffered during previous waves
but it will take serious restrictions
that reduce contacts it's going to be a
tough december in january it absolutely
will be
like everything else we'll get through
it we go through wave one two and three
we'll get through wave four if you do
choose to travel this holiday season
there's no one-size-fits-all answer
about insurance the group insurance
pretty clear you probably will be
covered i think the real question is
around those who have purchased
individual plans experts warn in
addition to checking your policy you
need to check out hospital capacities
where you're going and consider what may
happen if you test positive at your
destination and have to quarantine there
abigail beeman global news ottawa
covent cases are on the rise across the
country both new brunswick and nova
scotia are reporting their highest daily
caseloads since the start of the
pandemic manitoba is reporting its
highest count since june quebec confirms
more than 2 700 new cases today that's
the highest since january
in saskatchewan booster doses are being
accelerated in anticipation of omicron
taking hold there starting monday all
adults will be eligible for a booster
the gap between second and third doses
is being reduced to three months and
people are being urged to book as soon
as possible
unfortunate i know after 21 months of
dealing with covet 19 that we need to
today just conduct ourselves in our
communities
with
you know a significant degree of caution
no new restrictions were announced today
the premier says the focus is on
boosters and free rapid tests that are
being made available by the province
once again we are looking overseas to
countries already engulfed in omicron
and in the uk the picture is not
positive it reported more than 88 300
new infections today that broke the
daily case record for the second day in
a row even if omicron proves to be
milder than previous variants uk health
officials say it could still lead to a
surge in hospitalizations because of the
sheer volume of cases plus health care
workers are being infected and having to
stay home redmond shannon reports on the
surge and the response
the last scramble to paris yeah now we
we're lucky we arrived starting saturday
only french citizens and residents can
freely travel to france from the uk
another response to the rapid spread of
omicron that's crazy uh
that's already spread in france it's the
same in the uk when they banned from
south africa it was already there
omicron is seizing european leaders at
their first summit of the post-angela
merkel era with many countries
tightening travel rules superseding the
eu-wide covid pass scheme with the
increased spread of the virus that we
are seeing in many countries right now i
can understand that governments take
even further precautions before omicron
there was alpha first detected in kent
england prime minister boris johnson was
there on thursday
[Applause]
dismissing the idea of locking down a
pandemic weary population despite the uk
breaking another daily record for new
cases this is very different from last
year because what we have is the
additional protection of of the vaccines
and the ability to test
the uk's health security agency
estimates those infected with omicron
are passing it on to an average of three
to five others
south african data suggests
hospitalizations and deaths may be lower
but western countries like canada may be
watching what happens in the uk more
closely
the earliest that we will have reliable
data is the week between christmas and
new year and probably early january
the queen has cancelled her traditional
pre-christmas family lunch as a
precaution and more soccer matches have
been postponed amid a record number of
infections in the premier league from
the palace to the pitch the impacts of
omicron are everywhere redmond shannon
global news london
the situation and the rules are changing
fast canadians have been advised not to
travel outside the country but several
premiers have voiced concerns after
tuesday's meeting with the prime
minister the travel measures are being
put in place without the signs to back
them up our chief political
correspondent david aiken is with me now
david what are you hearing
yeah well that's exactly it donna we
have heard concerns from some premier's
offices that they felt the trudeau
government was trying to use that first
minister's call
earlier this week to build support for
new tougher travel restrictions
including renewed quarantines and bans
on inbound travel by non-canadians an
aide in one premier's office used the
phrase political theater to describe the
prime minister's call with the premiers
because they say the trudeau government
did not present data to back up requests
for new travel restrictions and that is
an important issue because it's easier
to get the canadian public to accept
tough new rules they may not like if
there is in fact evidence those rules
work but even dr howard knew he's
canada's deputy medical deputy chief
medical officer of health he conceded
that sometimes cabinet is making
decisions despite the absence of data we
recognize that there are other
considerations in play as well beyond
just a strictly sort of technical public
health advice that we may be giving to
ministers
david the government did not impose a
travel ban it is an advisory and there's
still a travel ban though on people
coming from 10 african countries
which many think should be revisited are
we likely to see changes and other
travel restrictions in the future
quite possibly here's what the transport
minister said this afternoon
i
tell you and canadians to expect
measures to be changed at any time
but if rules are changed the message
from experts is explain why
you really have an obligation ethically
if you're going to restrict freedom of
movement to explain to people exactly
how this decision was made now in the
meantime the only existing travel ban as
you mentioned is the one on travel from
those african countries and that ban
we're told is now under review why
because there is no data to suggest it
works donna all right david aiken in
ottawa thank you
we are going to put your questions about
omicron to the experts you can send any
questions you have to your questions at
globalnews.ca
well kovit19 was one of many complex
issues the prime minister had to deal
with in 2021 from an increasingly
belligerent china to the crisis in
canada's military and winning the
election prime minister justin trudeau
has had successes and failures this year
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson interviewed him today mercedes
what stood out to you as the prime
minister turns the page on 2021. well
donald we started out with the covet
discussion and it was really what we've
been hearing from the government over
and over but where we got some
interesting depth from prime minister
justin trudeau was on what happened when
the two michaels came home and as you
just mentioned it was one of the
standout moments not only for the
government but for canadians this year
in the interview with me prime minister
justin trudeau
revealed what michael kovrig said to him
when they landed back in canada that he
told the prime minister he in fact had
done the right thing by refusing to do a
prisoner transfer for mung wang zhou
here is what the prime minister told me
about that
it was
surprisingly emotional on a personal
level because as
a leader as a prime minister you want to
do the right thing
you know what the right thing is but
there's a human cost these two canadians
were stuck in terrible conditions
totally arbitrarily and there was at
least a theoretical way of me taking
shortcuts and backroom deals to get them
home
but i
i knew i felt that you had to do the
right thing and we stayed the course on
the right thing
and to hear
one of the michaels say to me
you did the right thing was
was satisfying on a personal level in
ways that uh that surprised even me
and the prime minister also talks about
taking a tougher line with china and a
tougher line with the canadian armed
forces when it comes to sexual
misconduct he talked about what the top
generals and admirals told him when the
sexual misconduct scandal first broke
when
the very
top levels of the military are insisting
that there is no problem
it is a challenge for any government to
say
okay you're wrong we're going to get rid
of all of you we're going to bring in an
entirely new system the prime minister
says he wishes he had done more sooner
in retrospect on the sexual misconduct
scandal there'll be more later but back
to you for now donna all right mercedes
in ottawa thank you in conversation with
the prime minister will air in full on
christmas day and on the west block on
boxing day
afghans still waiting to get to canada
coming up the tragic impact of delayed
rescue
[Music]
efforts the last remaining members of a
group of missionaries including one
canadian captured and held hostage for
two months in haiti are finally free
police in haiti say the 12 hostages were
found on a mountain the 17-member group
from the ohio-based christian aid
ministries was kidnapped by a gang in
october after visiting an orphanage in
port-au-prince
global affairs canada says it is aware
of the case and stands ready to provide
consular assistance to the canadian
during the last federal election justin
trudeau promised to bring 40 000 afghan
refugees to canada including those who
supported the canadian military mission
in afghanistan so far about 5 000
refugees have arrived in canada 5000
others have been approved but are still
waiting overseas for those trapped
inside taliban controlled afghanistan
evacuation efforts have stalled and as
jeff semple reports the delayed efforts
just cost one girl her life
speaking by phone from afghanistan
bashir tells me his ten-year-old
daughter nazifa was very bright at the
top of her class
she was learning english and really
excited to move to canada he says we're
protecting bashir's identity because he
worked for the canadian forces in
kandahar after the taliban took over in
august his family was approved to move
to canada but they're stuck with no way
out of the country
last week beshear's family was driving
past a taliban checkpoint they thought
the guard was waving them through but
then one of the talibans started
shooting at their vehicle the bullets
struck and injured his brother-in-law
and his niece bashir's daughter nasifa
was shot in the head and didn't survive
it's unclear why they were targeted but
bashir believes it was because he had
worked for the canadians
i am lost my daughter is gone and i'm
afraid for the rest of my family he says
there's a ten-year-old girl who was shot
in the face
when she should have been on her way to
canada i can say that with no doubt in
my mind this was on this was avoidable
uh and it was bound to happen
five months since ottawa announced its
special afghan refugee program thousands
who supported canada's military are
still in hiding many still waiting for
ottawa to process their applications we
cannot stay here anymore this former
interpreter submitted his application
last summer and hasn't received a
response but he did receive this letter
from the taliban ordering all those who
have worked with foreigners to appear in
court or the islamic emirate will deal
with them according to its laws he's
considering turning himself in to save
family daughter and my wife are crying
the
his
you know crying
for their future
since the trudeau liberals won
re-election in september until the first
week of december ottawa approved 165
afghan refugee applications that's an
average of fewer than two per day with
30 000 still to go but we need to do
better we need to pick this up
we need to get the jet the log jams
resolved the reality is mr speaker we've
made a substantial contribution a
spokesperson for the immigration
minister says several flights arrived
just last week carrying hundreds of
afghans
they include sahil now preparing to
celebrate christmas at his new home in
niagara falls but sahil's canadian
sponsor says the government is
misrepresenting the numbers canada since
the fall of the air bridge has gotten
nobody out of afghanistan the recent
arrivals like sahil are privately
sponsored refugees who are already
living outside afghanistan and eligible
to come to canada part of a separate
program from those who supported the
military and remain trapped we need to
focus on finding a viable solution
within afghanistan to get people out
ottawa expects it will take two years to
bring all 40 thousand refugees to canada
not soon enough for most families and
already too late for nazifa
jeff temple global news toronto
ahead scenes of devastation as more wild
weather rips through the u.s
in australia there's devastation for the
families of five children they died
after a bouncy castle was caught in a
gust of wind and lifted 10 meters into
the air it happened during an event to
mark the end of the school year two boys
and two girls were pronounced dead at
the scene another child died in the
hospital four others are in critical
condition and police say the victims
were in grade 6 and between 10 and 11
years old
there's been another bout of wild
weather in the united states tornadoes
damaging winds and a massive dust storm
ripped through the u.s midwest killing
at least five people the powerful
weather front pounded nebraska iowa and
minnesota with hurricane force winds and
suspected tornadoes if confirmed the one
in minnesota would be that state's first
ever in the month of december
sirens went off went down the basement
just a lot of bang everything looked
quiet and dark and come out in the
garage is gone you got power flashes
wind gusts topped 160 kilometers an hour
peeling back roofs and blowing semi
trucks over and in wisconsin trees and
power lines were knocked down cutting
power to thousands of people states of
emergency have been declared in iowa and
kansas the extreme weather system has
now shifted north to the great lakes and
into canada where several winter weather
warnings are in effect
healthcare worker burnout next what it
will take to turn the tide
[Music]
none of us can quite believe 2021 is
going to end with another variant having
a stranglehold on the world and it's
people who work in healthcare who are
bearing the brunt of the anguish in this
pandemic and who now look to 2022
wondering what's to come and how much
more they can take jamie morocco has
been talking to some of them
even with small reminders around like
this tiny tree or these shiny baubles
it's easy to forget about the holidays
instead tasley nimji and her staff are
preoccupied preparing for another wave
time is not on our side here with how
quickly omicron is spreading on the
front lines that means workers reaching
for n95s over surgical masks again
nerves here are shot people are simply
exhausted
we're already dealing with staffers like
strap shortages and high volumes
and so that's a challenging environment
to work in and now you're layering this
on top of that critical care capacity is
likely to be tested once more that work
is some of the hospital's most demanding
under normal circumstances and just one
new omicron case among staff could force
entire units into isolation we might be
looking at nursing ratios that need to
be one to three one to four and
that brings up its own issues in terms
of how do we keep everybody safe
frontline workers have seen this before
hospitals in alberta and saskatchewan
buckled under the strain of the third
wave provinces like manitoba have
already asked ottawa to send help more
icu nurses knowing what could happen if
an outbreak occurred at toronto's mount
sinai hospital nurse sarah beth silver
works with some of the most vulnerable
cancer patients she knows she has to do
everything she can to stay healthy
washing her hands wearing masks
minimizing contacts and getting boosted
i think we're taking the lessons that
we've learned from the first few waves
of the pandemic to take it into this
next phase nimgee says her teams are
ready to borrow staff from other units
and transfer patients if need be it's
hard
but but we have to do it we got to do it
left with the hope canadians will get
their third doses to help those who are
committed to helping us jamie morocco
global news
toronto and that is global national for
this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is the halifax
public gardens established in 1867 and
it's a special day for nova scotia the
population surpassed 1 million today the
first atlantic province to reach that
mark
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]